ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen wir
blicken auf den Krieg im Nahen Osten und
vor allem auf die Lage der
Zivilbevölkerung im Gazastreifen die
Terrororganisation Hamat nutzt die
eigenen Bürger als menschliche
Schutzschilde und versteckt sich und
ihre Waffen in Mitten ziviler
Einrichtungen und bringt Israel damit in
ein Dilemma geht diese Taktik der Hamas
auf als zunehmend dramatisch wird die
Lage in den Krankenhäusern in Gaza
beschrieben die Bilder die wir jetzt
sehen stammen aus dem schifahkrankenhaus
in gas Stadt eine der größten Kliniken
im Gasastreifen für die Patienten die
dort noch versorgt werden wird die Lage
offenbar immer schlimmer das Krankenhaus
meldete am Wochenende dass der letzte
Generator keinen Treibstoff mehr habe
und das Gesundheitsministerium das von
der Hamas kontrolliert wird hat Fotos
veröffentlicht dass mehrer Neugeborene
zeigt die demnach dringend versorgt
werden
müssten wir sprechen darüber mit
Christian lindmeier er ist Sprecher der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO die
ihren Hauptsitz in Genf hat und deshalb
ist er uns aus der Schweiz zugeschaltet
schön dass Sie bei uns sind Herr
lindmeier lassen Sie uns direkt über die
Situation der Neugeborenen sprechen und
dazu möchte ich gerne kurz hier auf
meinen Monitor gehen und einen Post der
IDF zeigen also der israelischen
Streitkräfte die zeigen soll wie man
dort bereit ist Inkubatoren also
Brutkästen für Babys in den
gazaastreifen zu liefern Herr lindmeier
wie ist diese Situation im Moment aus
ihrer
Sicht die die Situation in Gaza
allgemein und in den betroffenen
Krankenhäusern die die äh
so stark unter Beschuss sind oder ist
natürlich verheerend und erstmal guten
Abend Frau ung stermerkt danke für
dieses hier ähm es fehlt an allen den
Ecken und Enden es ist ja seit 7 seit 8
Oktober sind ja schon die
versorgungskanäle zugespert es gibt kein
Frischwasser es gibt kaum noch Strom der
letzte in den einigen Krankenhäusern ist
auch schon abgeschaltet weil keine
Generatoren mehr gehen es gibt kaum was
zu essen nur 5% Frischwasser wie gesagt
die müllsituation ist verherend also
jeder der Müll muss quasi auf die Straße
nicht nur der normale Hausmüll sondern
auch der inische Müll das mischt sich
mittlerweile leider auch mit
menschlichen Kadavern Regenfälle haben
eingesetzt den Gase also die Situation
für alle die ganze Bevölkerung dort ist
verherend der Ausbruch von weiteren
Krankheiten Infektionskrankheiten
Lungenkrankheiten ist durchaus
vorprogrammiert und natürlich bekommen
die Verletzten und auch die mit normalen
Krankheiten dialysatienten
Asthmapatienten was auch immer
Krebspatienten keine ausreichende
Versorgung mehr Herr lind lassen sie uns
ganz lassen sie uns ganz kurz ähm damit
wir alles nacheinander gut bearbeiten
können jedes Thema für sich lassen sie
uns ganz kurz noch auf die Babys schauen
wie wichtig wären denn diese Inkubatoren
dass sie in dem Krankenhaus
ankommen
also was wir gehört haben soll es sicher
um quasi batteriebetriebene Inkubatoren
geben das wäre sicher sehr gut denn was
das problemmoment ist dass die
Inkubatoren die es gibt keerlei
Stromversorgung mehr haben und damit
natürlich nutzlos sind
batteriebetriebene inkubaden sind
hervorragend die Frage ist was dann
danach was soll dort passieren die
können ja oder die Idee scheint ja nicht
zu sein die dann dort in dem alschiva
Krankenhaus zu lassen sondern weiter zu
transportieren und dann ist die Frage
wohin also a erste Mal eine gute
Initiative wenn diese wirklich genutzt
werden können so wie sie vorgesehen
sind das rettet sicherlich leben aber
das kann ja auch nur eine Zeit sehr
zeitbegrenzte Maßnahme sein und es muss
weitergedacht werden was kommt danach
werden die verlegt können die verlegt
werden mit welchen Fahrzeugen mit
welchem medizinischen Personal und vor
allem wohin in Gasa es gibt und das ist
ganz wichtig in Gaza keinen sicheren
Fleck im Moment wenn es so ist Herr
lindenmeierer wäre es denn eine
Möglichkeit aus diesem gaserastreifen
heraus Patienten nach Israel zu bringen
wäre das eine Möglichkeit die Sie in
Betracht ziehen würden und was müsste
dafür geschehen damit das passieren kann
also in der Theorie ist das sicher
möglich es wurden ja schon einige wenn
auch nur sehr
wenige stark erkrankte oder auch stark
verletzte Personen evakuiert es ist ein
ganzes Netz aufgebaut also das die die
die Logistik ist aufgebaut von der
palästinensischen roten halbm und der
das bis zur Grenze übernehmen könnte
dann über die Gren dann übernehmen
wiederum von dem ägyptischen roten
halbmund und in ein erstes Krankenhaus
Verlegen von wieder weiter verteilt wird
also die Logistik ist
aufgebaut jetzt speziell mit
Spezialgebieten Spezialgeräten wie
diesen Inkubatoren da bin ich mir nicht
sicher ob die richtigen Fahrzeuge
vorhanden sind aber Lehmen wir mal an
das geht also die Logistik würde stehen
es ist auch schon gemacht worden die
Frage ist es muss natürlich s nicht nur
mittlerweile glaube reden wir von 34
Kleinkindern oder BAB weil drei von den
37 ursprülich ja wohl glücklicherweise
schon gestorben sind da müssten ja wohl
entweder Familien oder zumindest Mütter
mit das heißt wir reden hier von einem
relativ großen Pulk von Leuten der durch
den ganzen Gasa hindurch transportiert
werden müsste auf sicheren Straßen ohne
unterbeschuss zu bekommen und dann
übergeben werden müsste noch mal in der
Theorie von der Logistik alles machbar
es müssten aber die Sicherheitsgarantien
gegeben sein und es müssten alle
kriegsfühenden Parteien das schließ die
Hamas mit ein ähm und natürlich dann
auch diplomatischerweise
Ägypten damit einverstanden sein es
lässt sich machen ähm Liebe Userinnen
und User wir seid natürlich herzlich
eingeladen Fragen an Herr lindmeer zu
stellen schickt sie uns an die bekannte
E-Mailadresse wenn ihr die App nutzt an
zdfheute-li@zdf.de oder über Youtube und
Facebook natürlich wie immer in die
Chats äh Herr lindmeierer sie haben
gerade schon beschrieben wie die
Situation in den anderen Krankenhäusern
ist wie ist aus ihrer Sicht ähm die Lage
mit äh Essen Getränke Medikamenten zuvor
Strom können Sie das noch mal ein
bisschen
schildern Gase hat ungefähr 5 % 6 %
vielleicht Frischwasser äh Zufluss der
Rest kommt von einem äh See unter dem
untergaser der stark von Salzwasser vom
Meer infiltriert ist das heißt Sie
müssen es erst natürlich hochpumpen und
und dann entsalzen fürs hochpumpen und
für das entsalzen braucht es Strom
braucht es Generatoren braucht es
braucht das Benzin Treibstoff und diesen
gibt es nicht mehr und wird natürlich
auch von Israel nicht mehr zugelassen da
es als duales gut auch dem Zweck der
Hamas dienen könnte und das sind ist der
Grund warum solche Güter nicht
eingeführt werden also Frischwasser ganz
ganz rar
Bäckereien oder sonstiges die auch mit
Str um betetrieben werden
dasselbe die sind fast am Ende
medizinische Versorgung ganz allgemein
ganz schlecht von von normalen
Wundverbänden über Blut das ausgetauscht
werden müsste über spezialisierte Geräte
eben wie gesagt für Dialyse für
Krebspatienten und sonstiges
krebskrankenhäuser das einzige richtige
krebskrankenhaus ist schon länger nicht
mehr funktionabel eine anderes das eine
eine krebsabteilung hat war bis zum
Wochenende noch halbwegs funktional aber
auch das scheint zu schließen Herr
lindmeier während wir hier gerade Bilder
sehen wie Menschen für Nahrung für
Lebensmittel
anstehen die auch in den Süden des
Landes flüchten das sehen wir hier
gerade wir sehen Kinder die Hände
ringend nach nach
Nahrung für für Nahrung anstehen also
auch diese Bilder beschreiben eine
zunehmend dramatische Lage und wie
gesagt hier auch Bilder von Menschen die
in den Süden flüchten wo es vermeintlich
sicherer ist und dazu kommt hier eine
eine Frage von einem User über Youtube
ich übersetze das mal so ein bisschen
der fragt die WHO könnte doch super
schnell eigene Krankenhäuser errichten
containerkrankenhäuser die UN zu denen
die WHO ja gehört sollten doch an der
Spitze von Technik Logistik und
Wissenschaft sein warum können sie das
nicht
machen es gibt verschiedene Wege es gibt
die verschiedene den Weg der der der
Airlift wie heiß noch aus der Luft
Material AbZ lassen es gibt auch schon
eine die Türkei hat glaube ich ein
krankenhausschiff in der Nähe der Raffa
Seite aber auf ägyptischer Seite
natürlich schon positioniert die
Franzosen haben das auch angeboten wir
haben tatsächlich auch diese sogenannten
emergency medical Teams also diese
Notfall Teams die aus verschiedenen
Ländern kommen die auch
notfallkrankenhäuser feldkrankenhäuser
aufbauen können aber lassen Sie nicht
vergessen es ist eins ein
feldkrankenhaus irgendwo aufzubauen wo
es vielleicht ein Erdbeben gab oder wo
es eine zukatastrophe gab und die
zeitbegrenzt etwas Hilfe und
Erleichterung schaffen können das ist
das eine das andere ist aber sie hätten
eigentlich ein funktionierendes jeemals
funktionierendes Gesundheitssystem im
Gaza und das einfachste und weit we
effektivere wäre diese Krankenhäuser das
bestehende System zu unterstützen denn
auch die medizinischen
notfallkrankenhäuser oder irgendwas
anderes was im Gaser aufgebaut werden
würde müsste ja wiederum versorgt werden
und das muss wiederum der Zustimmung äh
Israels äh vor allem geschehen und ob
jetzt diese rankenhäuser versorgt werden
oder die schon bestehenden da ist es um
einiges sinnvoller die zu versorgen und
wieder auszurüsten wieder aufzupushen
einfach mit Strom mal anzufangen die es
schon gibt also äh wir brauchen nicht
ein neues System erfinden das alte ist
da es muss nur unterstützt werden nur in
ein ganz großen Anführungsstrichen mm
Herr lindmeierer hier fragen sich
mehrere UserInnen
W W ihre Kontakte vor Ort sind oder wer
ihre Leute vor Ort sind eine Userin
namens Marianne Schmidt fragt über
Facebook wie wie eng arbeitet die WHO
mit der Hamas zusammen ich gebe die
Frage jetzt einfach mal so weiter wie
sie hier gestellt wurde und ich würde
sie eher übersetzen in was sind ihre
Quellen vor Ort wer sind die Leute die
für die WHO dort arbeiten also wir haben
zum einen unser eignes Personal dort und
danke für die Frage das ist gar nicht
unwichtig wir haben unser eigenes
Personal da nationales und internation
nationales
die aber hauptsächlich nicht selber
Handanlegen im Sinne von Ärzten sondern
die mehr auf der Verwaltungsebene
arbeiten also mit Logistik viel zu tun
haben mit und dann eben mit der
Zusammenarbeit mit nationalen
Kranken Behörden also dem den den dem
Ministerium in jedem Land ist es so wo
die WHO zur Nothilfe eingreift also auch
in Ländern wo es normalerweise einfach
unter normalen Umständen it die WHO mit
dem Gesundheitsministerium zusammen
jetzt haben wir natürlich die Situation
dass im Gaza das Gesundheitsministerium
der quasi der facto Regierung unterliegt
und das ist natürlich der politische Arm
der der Hammers also wir müssen
notgedrungen mit dem politischen Arm
zusammenarbeiten aber wir arbeiten mit
den den krankenbehörden dort schon seit
Jahrzehnten zusammen über impfkabagen
über Routineimpfungen bei Kleinkindern
andere gesundheitsausbrüche und und und
und und haben dort sehr gute Erfahrung
gemacht und von Ideologie war auf der
Ebene ich unterstreiche auf der Ebene
noch nie etwas zu sehen mhm okay also
soweit sie sagen können über ihre
Zusammenarbeit hier wird unter anderem
gefragt ob es auch Opfer unter den
Hilfsorganisationen gibt sehr viele
leider sogar die unra die also die UN
relief and works agency die eigentlich
für die palästinensischen Flüchtling
Linge in Gaza aber auch in der Westbank
und in Syrien und im Libanon zuständiges
hat schon über 100 Tote zu beklagen das
sind also vor allem Lehrer ähm auch
Mitarbeiter von Logistikzentren aber vor
allem Lehrer weil die die UN ein sehr
großes Schulsystem beklagt wir selber
die WHO wir haben meines Kenntnis nach
noch keinen Mitarbeiter dort verloren
andere Hilfsorganisation haben aber
durchaus schon äh tote vermeldet wir
wissen dass über 100 Tote
ähm gesundheitsmitarbeiter also
Pflegepersonal in Gaza gibt
ähm davon 16 mindestens 16 die während
ihrer Arbeit gestorben sind also während
sie auf andere kranke und verwundete
aufgepasst haben gepflegt haben sind
diese
umgekommen Christian lindmeier der
Sprecher der WHO vielen Dank dass Sie
bei uns im Stream waren danke schön für
ihre Eindrücke die die Kollegen von
Vorort in gerichtet haben danke schön
und wir sprechen weiter in der Sendung
über dieses Dilemma was hier auf Youtube
ein User namens Markus Spinola folgend
beschreibt völkerrechtlich ist
jedenfalls nicht abgedeckt wer zivile
Einrichtungen als Waffenlager
Terrorzellen und damit als Schutzschild
nutzt und damit sind wir genau da was
das israelische Militär gerade
veröffentlicht hat
wir sehen Bilder aus dem Keller eines
Krankenhauses in Gaza und hiermit will
die israelische Armee erneut belegen
dass die Hamas zivile Infrastruktur als
Versteck nutzt zu sehen sind hier unter
anderem eine Babyflasche die man hier
sieht man sieht auch Stühle und hier
eine Toilette und damit soll eben
gezeigt werden dass die Amas offenbar
auch diese Räumlichkeiten genutzt hat um
oder dass es Anzeichen dafür gibt dass
die Hamas hier Geiseln gehalten hat und
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit unserem
nächst Gesprächspartner das ist Gil
jaron er ist israelischer Arzt und
Journalist und er leitet das Büro des
landesnordrhein-westfalen in Israel er
lebte bis vor kurzem in Tel Aviv und ist
uns jetzt aus Düsseldorf zugeschaltet
Herr jaron wir haben gerade ein
mutmaßliches Versteck gesehen wo
israelische Geiseln gehalten wurden was
wissen Sie aktuell über
die Lage der
Geiseln über die Situation der Geisel
ist im Augenblick ja noch nichts bekannt
nur die chamas hatte ja vor ganz kurzer
Zeit ein sehr makabres Video
veröffentlicht ein Interview mit eine
mit einer 19-jährigen Geisel
und kurz nach dem Interview wurde ein
Foto von ihr gezeigt wie sie tot auf dem
Boden liegt und die Hamas machte dafür
die israelische Luftschläge
verantwortlich
das es so ein ein Video der chamas mit
dem man versuchte psychologische
Kriegsführung gegen die israelische
Militäraktion durchzuführen aber
zugleich werden jetzt auch Neuigkeiten
bekannt dass die Israelis in
fortgeschrittenen Verhandlungen sind
über Ägypten und wahrscheinlich auch
über Katar für die Entlassung der
Geiseln US-Präsident Joe Biden hat sich
jetzt vor ganz kurzer Zeit sehr
optimistisch geäußert und nun wurde
bekannt dass der Chef des israelischen
Inlandsgeheimdienstes sich in diesen
Minuten in Ciro befindet wahrscheinlich
um die letzten Details eines Austausches
von verschleppten gegen palästinensische
Gefangene in Israel auszuhandeln äh und
man spricht dort von dutzenden wenn ich
vielleicht sogar von einer niedrigen
dreistelligen Zahl von Gefangenen die
freikommen könnte aber genaue Details
sind im Augenblick noch nicht bekannt
aber im Augenblick herrscht ein bisschen
mehr Optimismus was das betrifft Herr
jaron es gibt auch ein Zitat von
US-Präsident Joe Biden und ich glaube
das hat fast wortgleich auch der
israelische Minister so formuliert
haltet durch wir kommen sagt Joe Biden
wie gesagt ist das so zu verstehen also
das hört sich eher wie eine militärische
Lösung an wir wir kommen unsere Soldaten
sind da um euch zu holen oder ist das
eher im Sinne eher im Sinne einer
Verhandlungslösung zu verstehen wie Sie
es gerade formuliert
haben ja er gab das er gab diese Antwort
im Zusammenhang mit der Frage wo die
Verhandlungen stehen also nicht
keine militärische Lösung und wenn er
sagt wir kommen dann würde er ja
wahrscheinlich mein amerikanische
Soldaten und nicht israelische Soldaten
und es gibt ja im Augenblick kein keine
Aussicht darauf dass die Amerikaner
irgendwie militärisch im Gasastreifen
Eingreifen werden und so beziehe ich das
ausschließlich auf die Verhandlung die
im Augenblick stattfinden nun hat
Brasiliens Präsident Lula la Silva
Israel aktuell vorgeworfen
mehrere Akte von Terrorismus zu begehen
m wie werden diese Vorwürfe in Israel
aufgenommen ja solche Vorwürfe egal
woher sie kommen die lösen in Israel
große Empörung auf weil man dort ja
eigentlich sehr darauf bedacht ist weil
man sich des internationalen Druckes
bewusst ist äh sich an Kriegsrecht zu
halten in der israelischen Armee läuft
es ja so dass fast jeder Luftschlag ja
auch von Juristen begleitet wird die in
dem einsatzkommandoraum sitzen und bevor
ein Luftschlag stattfindet werden die
befragt ist das aus juristischer Sicht
abgedeckt ähm weil man sich in Israel
bewusst ist man ist ein kleines Land man
ist ein verletzliches Land man ist
internationalen Druck ausgesetzt und
israelischen Reservisten die im
Augenblick in Gazastreifen ihren Dienst
tun die möchten später keinen
internationalen Haftbefehl gegen sich
ausgestellt sehen und versuchen sich
deswegen ein internationales Kriegsrecht
zu halten zumal Israel ja auch ein
Interesse hat dieses Kriegsrecht
einzuhalten aus zwei Gründen zum einen
ist aus israelischer Sicht zumindest ist
dies kein Krieg gegen das Israel gegen
das palästinensische Volk sondern gegen
die Hamas und zum zweiten ist jeder
Bruch des internationalen Rechts ja
einen Anlass weiteren Druck auf Israel
auszuüben und das würde bedeuten dass
Israel immer weniger Zeit zur Verfügung
hat um das zu machen wofür sie
eigentlich da sind nämlich die Hamas die
Infrastruktur die militärische
Infrastruktur der Hamas zu zerstören
dafür brauchen Sie Zeit und dafür
brauchen sie
ein Kredit die in die ein zeitkredit den
die die internationale
Staatengemeinschaft gewährt hier gibt es
noch eine Frage zu den Geiseln ähm
jemand fragt über Youtube an
usernernamen StepStone es gibt über 670
Kinder in israelischer Haft könnten die
nicht ausgetauscht werden ich weiß nicht
ob sie zu der Zahl was sagen können aber
es gibt ja offenbar mehrere
100 Frauen und Jugendliche aus
aus dem Gazastreifen die in in
israelischer Haft sind korrigieren Sie
mich bringen sie die Zahlen mal in
Ordnung
bitte ich kenne jetzt die genaue Zahl
der Minderjährigen in israelischer Haft
nicht wenn ich mich richtig erinnere
reden wir auch von einer niedrigen
dreistelligen Zahl wenn wir von
palästinensischen Frauen sprechen die
sich in israelischer Haft befinden
nun gibt's aber einen qualitativen
Unterschied zwischen denen und die sich
im gaserstreifen befinden im
gaserstreifen kamen Menschen in das
Wohnzimmer der der Bewohner der Umgebung
des gaserstreifens und haben von dort
jeden verschleppt den sie gesehen haben
von dem 10 Monate alten quir
quir bibas der gerade angefangen hat zu
zu zu krabbeln bis hin zu
85-jährigen während sich die
palästinensischen gefängnisinassen dort
nach einem ordentlichen Gerichtsprozess
befinden und sie verurteilt wurden für
verschiedene Akte
nun kann man natürlich sagen ein Teil
von diesen Menschen wie in jedem
Gerichtssystem sind nicht zurecht
verurteilt und bei minderigen ist das
Problem definitiv noch größer aber ich
glaube erstmal kann man das hier
qualitativ nicht vergleichen aber
dennoch wovon im Augenblick die Rede ist
dass man die weiblichen verschleppten in
der
hamashaft versucht oder Gefangenschaft
versucht auszutauschen gegen zumindest
ein Teil der Frauen und Minderjährigen
die sich in israelischen Gefängnissen
befinden hier gibt es eine weitere Frage
über Youtube was können wir Europäer
machen wie können wir die zivile
Bevölkerung unterstützen bzw helfen nur
Spenden
Fragezeichen ich glaube spenden ist eine
Sache ich glaube auch dass die Europäer
natürlich darauf dass sie pochen dass es
humanitäre Korridore gibt darauf dass
sie pochen dass es Feuerpausen gibt in
denen die Zivilbevölkerung sich in
Sicherheit bringen kann das ist eine
Sache aber man kann natürlich auch noch
an andere Lösungen denken natürlich kann
man feldhospitäle aufbauen und die
hätten in Ägypten zumindest einem
Vorteil unter solchen feldkrankenhäusern
die jetzt von europäischen Nationen
aufgebaut würden oder krankenhausschiffe
wie beispielsweise die Türkei sie
entsandt hat
darunter bewürde sich kein Bombenkeller
der Hamas befinden darunter könnte die
Hamas keine Raketen lagern und sie
später abschießen das heißt das wärden
wirklich sichere Zufluchtsorte für
Menschen aus dem Gazastreifen nur dafür
bräuchte man die Zustimmung von Ägypten
die es ja im Augenblick noch nicht gibt
oder vielleicht die Zustimmung sogar
Israels es werden ja sogar Palästinenser
auch in Israel behandelt auch das kommt
ja vor eine letzte Frage ähm geht in
Richtung Westjordanland wie ist die
Situation dort können Sie dazu was
sagen ja auch da eskaliert die Lage
fortwährend wir haben äh wir sehen da
immer mehr Tote eigentlich auf beiden
Seiten wir sehen immer mehr
Zusammenstöße zwischen der israelischen
Armee und den Palästinensern und diese
Zusammenstöße die eskalieren nicht nur
quantitativ sondern auch qualitativ wir
sehen hier dass die Israelis sogar
inzwischen neuerdings dazu zurückgreifen
ihre Luftwaffe einzusetzen in Form von
Drohnen dass also Luftschläge
durchgeführt werden gegen
palästinensische Terrorzellen und auch
hier sehen wir wieder ähnliche Taktiken
der Hamas erst heute wieder wurde ein
hochrangiger gesuchter Hamas Kommandant
von einer terrorbrigade im Norden des
Westjordanlands gefasst nämlich indem er
versuchte innerhalb von einem
Krankenwagen aus der Stadt zu fliehen in
der man nach ihn suchte also auch hier
wide dieselben Taktiken zivile
Einrichtungen und eigentlich geschützte
internationale Zeichen werden hier
missbraucht um den Krieg gegen die
israelische Gesellschaft weiterzuführen
so im Gazastreifen so auch im
Westjordanland und darauf reagiert
Israel im Augenblick sehr hart und da
ist großes
Eskalationspotenzial vielen Dank gilaron
dass Sie bei uns in der Sendung waren
ähm alles Gute für Sie
tschüss
danke und damit gehen wir direkt weiter
zu unserem Korrespondenten Vorort
Michael bwerunge ist in Tel Aviv uns
jetzt zugeschaltet Michael und du warst
heute morgen eurer Zeit bei einem
Briefing der israelischen Armee was
wurde da berichtet wie schildert das
israelische Militär seine Fortschritte
im
Gazastreifen
also zunächst mal das ist auch nicht
kein physisches treffen sondern ist ein
Zoom Meeting wie das wahrscheinlich
viele Menschen in diesen Zeiten kennen
dadurch läuft das zwar etwas
distanzierter ab aber dadurch auch ein
bisschen geordneter und ein
Armeesprecher der trägt vor und
Journalisten können Fragen stellen
manches ist offen manches ist nicht
offen heute war meist das meiste
offen heute wurde eigentlich nicht viel
Neues vorgetragen sonder vielleicht noch
mal zusammengefasst was in den letzten
Tagen schon von verschiedenen ähäh
Führern politischen Führern z.B dem
Verteidigungsminister auch vorgetragen
wurde nämlich dass die äh militärische
Infrastruktur
äh der Hamas zumindest im Norden von
Gaza dabei ist zusammenzubrechen
äh das machen die macht die Armee und
der Verteidigungsminister an mehreren
Punkten Fest zum einen fliehen immer
mehr Kämpfer äh zum einen sagt die Armee
jedenfalls wir können das natürlich
nicht konkret nachprüfen das ist
schlicht undmöglich aber es spricht viel
dafür dass es tatsächlich so ist zum
anderen sagt die Armee es ist uns
gelungen die hierarchische Struktur der
Armee der Hamas das ist ja auch eine
militärisch organisierte Struktur
durcheinander zu bringen wir haben viele
militärische Führer gezielt getötet
dadurch kann diese militärische Armee
der Hamas nicht mehr koordin
Entschuldigung muss mich einmal Räuspern
kann nicht mehr koordiniert agieren und
deswegen ist der Widerstand auch gegen
unsere Truppen sagt die israelische
Armee deutlich geringer und de facto
muss man einfach sagen dass wenn man die
verschiedenen Orte mal sich auf der
Karte anguckt wo gekämpftd wo die Armee
Israels bereits vorgedrungen ist einen
Großteil des nördlichen gasastreifens
umfasst also ein großer Teil des
nördlichen gaserstreifens erobert ist
was fehlt ist halt dieses vermutete
Hauptquartier unter dem Schifer Hospital
das vermutete Hauptquartier der Hamas
und da gibt es halt große Probleme wir
haben es am Anfang der Sendung gehört
wie stellt man eine Evakuierung an die
Israelis haben Inkubatoren für die Babys
Angeboten teilweise sicheren Transport
aber natürlich sind die Fragen
berechtigt wie geht es dann weiter die
Israelis haben übrigens auch 300 l
Treibstoff Angeboten angeblich hat die
Hamas das verhindert dass die
krankenhausdirekt diesen Treibstoff
angenommen hat also im Moment versucht
die israelische Armee dieses Krankenhaus
mit friedlichen Mitteln zu evakuieren um
dann allerdings den militärischen Kampf
gegen das vermutete Hauptquartier der
Hamas unter diesem Krankenhaus weiter
durchzuführen mhm Michael nachdem was du
beschreibst ist ja auch davon auszugehen
hast dass hamaskämpfer den Weg nach
Süden nutzen werden auch um zu flüchten
und jetzt muss man unterscheiden
zwischen auch da zwischen zivilbevölk
kerung die sich versucht in Sicherheit
zu bringen und
hamaskämpfern die jetzt in Richtung
Süden wandern was bedeutet das denn für
den Kampf Israel gegen Israels gegen die
Hamas wenn nicht nur der Norden sondern
jetzt auch der Süden quasi ein Gebiet
ist in dem man Terroristen
vermutet na ja ganz Gaza ist unter
tunnelt und die Hamas ist natürlich im
Norden wie im Süden präsent und
natürlich ist damit nur ein Teil des
Kampfes gewonnen wenn irgendwann mal
vielleicht der das gesamte Gebiet des
nördlichen gasastreifens eingenommen ist
der Großteil der Tunnel zerstört ist die
hamaskämpfer zumindest vertrieben wenn
noch nicht getötet sind
die Frage wie es dann weitergeht ist
eine offene Frage weil eine Million
Menschen ca sind aus dem Norden jetzt in
den Süden geflüchtet wenn die
israelische Armee sich vielleicht
irgendwann mal den süben vornehmen wird
und das wird sie müssen wenn sie die
hammas dauerhaft zerschlagen wird denn
die Hamas ist dort wird dort präsent
bleiben und hat dort nach wie vor
sichere
Unterschlupfmöglichkeiten die auch mit
1000 Bombardements nicht vollständig
vernichtet werden können dann stellst
die Frage wie geht das weiter wie sollen
die 2 Millionen Menschen dann wieder
zurück in den Norden also es gibt noch
sehr sehr viele offene Fragen was
eigentlich das Endziel der Strategie
Israels in diesem Krieg ist Michael wir
wollen dich jetzt nicht nicht zu lange
ähm quälen wir du kannst auch gerne dir
die Zeit nehmen und ein einen Schluck
Wasser trinken und dann machen wir
weiter das ist gar kein Problem hier im
Livestream haben wir ja die nötige Zeit
es gibt eine Frage zum Leben in Israel
und zwar ob es schon wieder ein ich
nehme jetzt nur ein Schluck Wasser um zu
beweisen ich nehme jetzt nur ein Schluck
Wasser um zu beweisen dass hier auch in
unserer Außenposition auf dem Dach sowas
sogar vom Kameramann gereicht wird das
ist echtes Teamwork das ist sehr gut
Grüße an die Kollegen Michael eine Frage
gibt es über Youtube ob es in Israel
schon wieder einen Arbeitsalltag gibt
oder ob die aktuelle Bodenoffensive
bedeutet dass die Wirtschaft und auch
Produktivität massiv darunter
leiden ja ich glaube das ist eine sehr
gute und sehr wichtige Frage nein es
gibt keinen
Alltag ich kann jetzt nicht beziffern
aber werden das demnächst mal genauer
vornehmen müssen das Thema wie groß der
Schaden für die Wirtschaft ist aber ein
großer te
sowohl Männer und Frauen sind in der
Armee eingezogen Reservisten sind
eingezogen und also das tägliche Leben
kommt auch allein schon dadurch zum
Erliegen dass viele Restaurants
Geschäfte geschlossen sind bestimmte
Einrichtungen wegen der Gefahr von
Raketenangriffen nicht geöffnet haben
also ganz Israel ist eigentlich noch mit
einem begrenzten Alltag vorhanden die
meisten Menschen sind auch nicht me auf
den Straßen bleiben zu Hause arbeiten
von zu Hause wenn das irgendwie geht und
mit Sicherheit hat das massive
Konsequenzen auf die Entwicklung der
Wirtschaft es gibt bereits verschiedene
auch politische Fragen die sagen wir
müssen eigentlich viel mehr Geld in die
Unterstützung der Wirtschaft Steuern äh
es gibt verschiedene Startup
Inter gewisse bestimmte Startup Ideen um
quasi die Wirtschaft wieder anzukurbeln
aber noch ist nicht klar wie groß der
Schaden ist durch diesen Krieg auch
allein schon was da an Material
verpulvert wird an militärischen
Ressourcen an Waffen und was gerade der
Wirtschaft an Wirtschaftsleistung
verloren geht und wie das wieder
eingeholt oder wieder aufgebaut werden
kann Michael der Stream hat den Titel
geht die Taktik der Hamas auf das war
die Frage die wir uns gestellt haben und
die möchten wir auch dir jetzt stellen
und ist das natürlich eine eine Frage
die erst in ein paar Wochen
wahrscheinlich zu zu beantworten ist
aber stand heute
wie würdest du eine Antwort auf diese
Frage versuchen zu
finden also ich würde sagen leider aber
de facto ist die Strategie der Hermas
weitgehend aufgegangen sie hat eine
komplette Polarisierung
geschaffen in der sich anbadenden
Annäherung von Israel und der arabischen
Welt sie hat einen konkreten Konflikt
maximal eskaliert en lassen dadurch
quasi auch die
zwangssolidarisierung mit der Hamas
gefördert sie hat im Prinzip den Krieg
der Bilder bereits gewonnen das
narrativ viele Menschen haben vergessen
was am 7 Oktober an furchtbaren
greulteltaten bewusst absichtlich in
mörderischer Absicht gegen Zivilisten
verübte Greueltaten verübt worden ist
dass bis jetzt verbrecherische Kidnapper
immer noch über 203 30 Geisel ihrer
Gewaltaten die Nutzen für Ihr zynisches
Spiel und dass Israel jetzt ein im
Prinzip gerechtfertigten
selbstverteidigungskrieg führt um diese
Bedrohung auszuschalten gerät angesichts
der Bilder die natürlich auch schlimm
sind und man muss natürlich auch Israels
Taktik zu
hinterfragen das ist natürlich ein
Vorteil für die Hamas Israel bemüht sich
und sagt das immer wieder wir versuchen
die humanitäre Kriegsführung einzuhalten
aber ich glaube humanitäre Kriegsführung
ist ein Widerspruch in sich man sagt man
versucht die Zivilisten zu schützen aber
de facto man kann viel über die Zahlen
streiten aber die Größenordnung werden
wohl ungefähr stimmen dass mehrere
tausend Zivilisten getötet worden sind
darunter viele Kinder und natürlich ist
die Frage die sich im Einzelfall stellt
muss das sein und für Israel ist das
quasi unmöglich bei einer Kriegsführung
zu beweisen dass es wirklich alles
versucht hat um diese äh Opfer zu
vermeiden äh das ganze polarisiert sich
am Streit um die Krankenhäuser haben wir
gesehen die Hamas benutzt natürlich in
jeder Beziehung die eigene Bevölkerung
als suschild wenn man so will als
Geiseln und für die Israelis ist es
zumindest in der Außenwirkung extrem
schwer dagegen anzukommen und natürlich
muss ich auch Israel fragen lassen ist
tatsächlich jedes einzelne Bombardement
jeder einzelne Angriff wirklich
gerechtfertigt Michael ich würde gern
zum Ende des Streams noch was mit dir
besprechen weil das uns oft vorgeworfen
wird in der Berichterstattung in den
Streams auch jetzt aktuell in diesem
Stream wieder dass wir zu wenig Menschen
aus Gaza selbst zu Wort kommen lassen
und hier fragt ein User auf Youtube
warum berichtest du nicht aus Gaza das
sind jetzt zwei verschiedene Sachen eine
dazu inwiefern wir versuchen auch aus
Gasa zu berichten und oder oder das
Stimmungsbild dort abzubilden dass wir
beide Seiten quasi abdecken und das
andere wie sind denn die
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten für euch zu
berichten in G aus
Gaza also das kann man sehr genau
beantworten ich würde erstmal dem
Fragesteller empfehlen einfach mal ZDF
Programm zu gucken wir haben gestern
quasi ausschließlich aus Gaza mit
Schwerpunkt aus Gaza berichtet wir haben
ein eigenes producerteam in Gaza was
seit langer Zeit mit uns
zusammenarbeitet für dass ich auch die
Hand ins Feuer lege die sind nicht
hammerstreu die stellen unsere Fragen
und recherchieren in die Richtung die
wir Ihnen vorgeben die sind aber im
Süden des Landes und im Norden kommt
keiner hin ich selber komme quasi
überhaupt nicht in den Gazastreifen rein
es sei denn mit der israelischen Armee
meiner Kollegin Katrin Eigendorf ist das
als embeded Journalistin am Sonntag
gelungen zusammen mit anderen
Journalisten viele Journalisten sind
schon da die israelische Armee bevorzugt
weitgehend die
Medien der der großen amerikanischen
Station oder auch BBC und als deutscher
Sender stehen wir den nicht ein Nummer
eins aber Moment habe ich z.B gerade
eine Anfrage laufen dass auch ich jetzt
wieder nach Gaza reinkomme das wird nur
als embedded also im Rahmen der Truppen
die sich dort bewegen möglich sein aber
dann zumindest einen eigenen Eindruck
von den Geschehnissen vor Ort zu
bekommen und der eigene Eindruck ist
durch nicht zu ersetzen aber ist sehr
schwierig auch aus Sicherheitsgründen
wäre es völlig utopisch dass ich jetzt
mit einem eigenen Team äh mich in Gasa
frei bewegen
könnte dann freuen wir uns auf einen
Stream mit Dir wo Du dann aus eigener
Hand berichten kannst und die Frage
eines anderen Users beantworten kannst
wie ist denn der Alltag gerade in Gaza
also mit diesem Ausblick auf kommende
Sendungen sage ich vielen dank Michael
bwerunge für den Moment nach Tel Aviv
und an dich und das ganze Team bis zum
nächsten Mal tschüss
danke und da it bedanke ich mich auch
bei Ihnen und Euch fürs kommentieren zu
diesem Thema heute wie die Lage im Gasa
Streifen ist bis zum nächsten Mal machen
sie es gut
tschüss